for less than 24 hours there was a
challenge to Russia's leadership by a
private Army who has played a key role
in Russia's invasion of Ukraine here's
how it unfolded
late Friday in Russia the leader of the
Wagner group evgeny pregozian claimed
that the Russian military killed an
enormous amount of his troops in an
artillery strike and that his forces
were going to cross into Russia calling
it the march of Justice
Russia responded by issuing an arrest
warrant for pregosian for Mutiny denying
his claims and a heavy military presence
appeared in Moscow
by early Saturday morning Wagner forces
were seen in rostov 600 miles south it's
the main logistical hub for Russian
forces operating in Ukraine pregosian
said that his forces had taken the city
is
in a televised address Russian President
Vladimir Putin responded and called for
his military to stop the Revolt is
foreign
stocked up on gas and cleared grocery
store shelves
meanwhile Wagner Vehicles were on the
move
they went along the M4 Highway which
goes northward straight to Moscow
where roadblocks began going up
about halfway 300 miles from Moscow in
varonish Russian military helicopters
opened fire on them a warehouse and fuel
tanks were destroyed and Wagner forces
reportedly shot down six Russian
helicopters and a plane
Wagner forces continued to move north
but by the time they were within 125
miles of Moscow a deal was reached
projects
the advance was over brokered by the
president of Belarus according to a
Putin spokesman the charges against
pregosian will be dropped and he will
move to the neighboring country
[Music]
ending an armed confrontation that
lasted less than 24 hours